>>> UK RUSSIA IS
THE OF ARTHREWI
IN T AND STRIKES ON N THE WEST.
UKRAINE IS BRACING FOR WHAT
MIGHT BE THE BLOODIEST
BATTLES D WAEE SO OE T
GENERAL RSONLTS BEEN
THE?>> I THINK TKR
ANDOE THEMSURRENDERING.
I KNOW THAT'S  TS NTS  HAPPENIN.
O O
RESOURCEFUL.
THEY REALIBE A
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND POLITICA
VICTORY FOR VLADIM PID.BANC
O TAKE, I
MORE TIME  R
THERE.
THEYBERE FOR SIXKSAND THEY HAVEO
BUT IT COULD
THATCOR BLOW TO TH.
NS OPERATIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT AS, E  BELIEVE.
E RUSSIANSTRYING TO REGROUP, TR
ART OF THE
R TH
WAWHAT WE CAN
EXPECT AND WHAT TIMELINE ARE WE
BATTLE FORHET FOR WHEN T
IG TO
.
>> I THINK STILLEE AWA
TH TACTICAL
COMBAT INEFFECTIVE.  F
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WLE
LIK OFF.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD ARMY.
THS A THIRD
POORLY LED, P,  ECU TACT SUDD R
THPROBY NTO VIOLATE
PRINCIPLE OFON
E  O
1200ILT.
D OF
SPOT, PROBABLY TOWARD K,
ALREADY HELD
RU AREAS,
UTILIZE INTERIO EP
THSEBRUTE FORCE,WARFARE,
HEAVY ARTILLERY,Y TOH
THEM OUT.
DONE HE CACKED AREA
E GREATEST LIKELI
PEOPLE TD ABOUT THEM COMINDOWN E
MBINED
THEYON INTEGRA
AVIATION, GROUYNNEIZS TO SI
EFFORTS.
UKRAINIAT NTVE'RE DU IN THOSAVE.
SUPPORTING THEM.
G TOE E
SUPPLY LINES
THEY'VE BEEN HAVIN F
IF
BATTALION TACTICAL GROUPS TO  I0
TH THEY CAN' ANS WILLUGEXPOSURE
THROUGH THE NORTH OR SOUTH
HTS WOULD BE
Y DORO
K AB AVE AT THE .
THE S. IS SET MORE
WEAPONS.
ME
HAVE BEEN ASKINGS, DRONE
HOWITZERS.
WHATS THE MOST IMP
HEREE
WE'VE BE TAL A WARFAREAD THE
AN'VE GOTHK D 3,00DRONES.
I THSON THINNILLD GY RESOURCEFU.
LIKE THEY TOOKUT THESKA  T AGE .
WHAT IS THICAL CHALLENGEAKE THA.
I USED AIFVALIDATER.LL
C17s.
THE C5s, WE CAN FLY TO POLAND IN
ESTABLISHED AN AIR BRIDGE  POLA
RELL.
DUSHINGWE CAN UAND BALL
ES WW AN TO
WE CAN TO MOVES MUCHWE CS.S ISH.
THUS FAR BECAUSE THE GAT SUPPOR.
WE CAN USE AE OF OR  THE MOST ET